hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the most popular
variations
in the queen's gambit so many people
interested not only in chess these days
but
in the queen's gambit opening which
starts out with d4
d5 and c4 so i thought it'd be a good
video
to go over the main variations that
you'll see
that black can actually play after white
plays
c4 i do have in-depth videos
on all the variations i'm going to cover
so if you ever want to check those out
you can head over to thechesswebsite.com
and check those that'll also have a link
in the description below to
my website but there's really four main
variations that you'll see
from black in the queen's gambit there's
two others that we'll discuss if you're
trying to catch your opponent off guard
but the first and most popular defense
in the queen's gambit is for black to
play
c6 this is the slob defense this is not
taking the pawn here on c4 that's the
accepted line
but to defend this central pawn here on
d5 white's really looking to give up
material here on c4
so that white now has the two central
pawns black
only has one central pawn here on e on
the e
file has given up his central pawn to
gain that material here
and the slav defense says that's not
what we're looking to try to do
we want to play c6 solidify
this pawn chain right here and protect
the central pawn
here on d5 most common line for white is
going to be to continue with knight to
f3
black plays knight to f6 and then white
has a couple options if
white plays e3 then black can play
bishop to
g4 and this is the the main slav line
you could also get into the semi-slav
line which is e6
this is blocking the light squared
bishop but solidifying the pawn chain
right here
it can become difficult for the light
square bishop to come outside this pawn
chain once
this pawn here is on e6 so some people
kind of have a preference if they play
the slav
or the semislav
the other defense for black that's just
as popular is the slob defense is the
queen's gambit orthodox line and that is
with
e6 solidifying the pawn here on d5
also preparing for the dark square
bishop to come outside
and attack the king prepare for a quick
castle on
the king side play normally resumes with
knight to c3
knight to f6 bishop down to g5
pinning down the knight to the queen
getting the bishop outside the pawn
chain before white plays pawn to e3
and you could see bishop to e7 stopping
the pin
e3 and then castle on the king side but
black has options to be tricky instead
of bishop to e7 could always play knight
to d7 getting into the elephant trap
which
there's another video i've done on that
trap you can definitely check that out
on the website but i'll go through it
real quick
pawn takes here on d5 pawn recaptures on
d5
white takes on d5 and it looks like why
would black
ever take this knight he's gonna lose
his queen doesn't matter that's exactly
what happens
after the bishop takes here bishop to b4
and you can see
check and the only way to not lose the
game
is to play queen to d2 so after the
bishop takes
king to d2 king takes here on
d8 and black is up a ton of material
coming in at the third most popular
variation is the accepted line and
that's if
black takes here on a c4 now the queen's
gambit not your typical gambit
black's going to gain material here on a
c4 but white can always get that
material back
black usually will just give the
material on c4 back
pretty quickly because if black does not
they're really going to ruin their
entire position
trying to hold on to that pawn so play
will typically resume with knight to f3
you could see knight to f6 pawn here to
e3
preparing for the bishop to come and
take here on c4 get that material back
here
pawn e6 bishop takes here on c4
and then pawn c5 since white has
the two pawns in the center of the board
black only has one
black using that c pawn which white
early on used their c
pawn to kind of attack the center of the
board that's exactly what black does
here and you can see the bishop on
f8 is protecting this pawn so if there
ever was an exchange
the bishop could take that with tempo
now they don't have to
play knight to f3 they could just play
something like e3 right away
so if they just want to capture that
material on at the next move they
absolutely could
there's four main variations that you'll
see in the queen's game but the fourth
one we're going to be looking at
not as popular as the other three but
definitely still we'll see it played and
that is the albin counter gambit and
that is
e5 here now i'm going to make a
reference to
the netflix series the queen's game but
if you haven't seen that i definitely
don't want to spoil anything for you
i'd recommend skipping forward about two
minutes in this video
that should make sure you don't catch
any spoilers but in the very last
game in that series you have beth harmon
playing borghoff for the world
championship beth harmon starts out with
the queen's gambit here
and borgob usually plays pretty
straightforward lines plays the move
e5 plays the albin counter gambit now
you hear that
said in the series and so this should
give you a better idea of what was
actually
played now the alvin kenner argument is
pretty tricky after the pawn takes on e5
which is undefended black plays the move
d4
this is a central wedge keeping these
pawns away from each other here and it's
difficult for white to deal with
the white's normally wanting to play
moves like knight to c3 which they can't
do
and so it's black has a lot of threats
that white has to deal with
you could play the the alaska trap so
maybe they try to play
uh e3 since they already have a central
pawn here on the e file they could try
to just chip away at this pawn
but then things like bishop to b4 are
tricky they can't play knight to c3 as
we talked about so
bishop two d2 and you get into this
weird trap
uh where check and then they can't take
the pawn because you could just take
their queen
and if they play e2 you could just under
promote to
a knight here and things get pretty
tricky there's another video i've done
on the alaska
trap all in all definitely not where
white would want to be
they just have to be aware of those
things now the main line instead of pawn
to e3
is going to just be knight to f3 uh
knight to c6 so
even as you're watching uh that last
match you can start to see
how this shapes up so when you see the
board you'll see okay i understand how
they got there
there are two more variations that
you'll see from time to time
uh they're both the chagoran as well as
the baltic
neither of these see a ton of play and
most times people will use them as
a surprise attack because the queen's
game is so popular for white
the score in defense is knight to c6
and then you have the baltic which is
bishop here to
f5 not going to go too much into the
theory on either of these i do have a
video on
both of those openings on the websites
definitely check those out if you want
to but hopefully you enjoyed
this video going over the main
variations
hopefully if you haven't spent too much
time on the queen's game but this gives
you a better understanding of the
options that black has if they're ever
met with the queen's gambit from white
if you haven't already please hit the
like button definitely helps
support the channel let me know what
your favorite variation in the queen's
game it is below
thank you guys so much watching the
video and i'll see you next time bye
you